and now we can join the foreign
secretary dominic raab to get the uk
government's reaction
to that election result in the united
states so we know that joe biden is
going to be the next president
is that going to be good news for the
united kingdom well okay first of all
congratulate uh
president-elect joe biden he's won with
more votes in history in any election we
congratulate vice vice president-elect
kamala harris she will be the first
black woman to hold that office
a landmark achievement and we're excited
by the opportunities for working with
the new administration
the contours adjust the the opportunity
some of the risks are just when there's
changes
in the white house but i'm very
confident uh from
climate change to cooperation on
coronavirus to counter terrorism
there's a huge bedrock of underlying
interests and values that bind us very
closely together
and when we look at what joe biden has
talked about doing in foreign policy
he will have no greater ally and
no more dependable friend in the united
kingdom i wonder if he would see it that
way though
because of course boris johnson has
previously written
in the past about barack obama's park
kenyan
ancestry and just yesterday a former
spokesperson for
president obama reacted to the prime
minister's congratulations with this
this
shape-shifting creep weighs in we will
never forget your racist comments about
obama and slavish devotion
to trump i mean it doesn't sound like
that relationship is going to be very
special does it
well look you can always pick uh
political campaigners and activists and
even advisors
i know from the work i've done with our
embassy in washington talking to
congressional leaders
across the house but including senator
chris coons very close to
president-elect biden i've talked to
nancy pelosi
i've talked to the uh irish caucus led
by
richie neal i know that of course
there'll always be
points of tension in any relationship
particularly the deepest and the most
profound ones
so you admit that might be a point of
tension then no no what i'm saying is
the bedrock the depth the range
of things that we do together and the
things that
uh that um president-elect biden wants
to achieve internationally
the things he's been talking about in
this campaign not just security council
terrorists in the middle east
but coronavirus and returning to the
paris climate agreement these are all
things which
particularly with our g7 presidency next
year and our
uh our hosting of cop26 i think that
we'll have a huge amount to cooperate on
and i'm excited about working
with the new administration um it's
interesting isn't it abiding campaign
insider is quoted in the sunday times
today as well
and saying that joe biden was shocked at
the dismissiveness of black rights
after you called the black lives matter
protesters taking the knee
a symbol of subjugation and
subordination and said you would only
kneel before the queen
or when proposing to your wife it sounds
like you might have a bit of
making up to do too well it's not my
impression from talking as i say to
congressional leaders across the house
including democrats but
look we absolutely committed to ending
racism zero tolerance racism
i think in a tolerant debate people
should be able to express that
solidarity with that incredibly
important principle
in their own way um but look as i said
you can always pick a snippet
from the newspapers or from activists
around the campaign what i know from
talking to
the leaders that i've spoken to that
we're going to have a very strong
relationship
and there's just so much that we can
cooperate on and so much of what
president-elect biden has been talking
about more international collaboration
on
uh coronavirus look at what the prime
minister did in hosting the gabby summit
uh which allows us to increase the
funding for equitable
access to a vaccine look at what joe
biden has said
around climate change we're hosting
cop26 next year i think very much the
pioneers in that space
so i i'm sure you'll be able to find
snippets of uh discord amongst uh in the
aftermath of a campaign
what i'm saying is i'm absolutely
confident in the bedrock of values and
interest
that we share and of course when america
wants to act in the world they've got as
i said no more reliable no more
dependable friend
than the united kingdom um i absolutely
accept that when it comes to
coronavirus and climate change as you've
mentioned we've got more in common with
uh
joe biden than donald trump are you
concerned though that it might be a bit
more tricky to do
a trade deal with joe biden than it
would have been with donald trump donald
trump of course has said that we would
be in front of the queue because of the
special relationship
he believes in brexit joe biden said
that he would have voted to remain and
joe biden's also said that any trade
deal between the us and uk
must be contingent upon respect for the
agreement withdrawal agreement
and preventing the return of a hard
border it's going to be harder to do a
trade deal with joe biden isn't it
i think we'll have to see but but let me
tell you what i know from having been
out to washington
and talk right through the the brexit
process to people like richie neil and
the irish caucus including
many democrats we were able to give them
positive reassurance when we signed
withdrawal agreement
i've been able to explain the uk
position uh we're the ones that have
been
unconditional in saying we'll never see
any infrastructure put up
at the border between the north and the
south in ireland and
we've uh of course listened to the
concerns of our american friends the
democrats who are very vested
in the good friday agreement we
understand that we look back at the work
of george mitchell bill clinton
and but i think it's also fair to point
out as i've used those opportunities in
washington
uh to do that that the eu is itself
putting pressure on the good friday
agreement with the approach it's taken
so i'm sure we'll have a sensible common
sense approach and actually i'm
you know when i look across the piece
that the issues uh
i'm looking forward to the opportunities
that we'll have and i and i'm confident
uh that the relationship between the uk
and the us will thrive in the
weeks and months ahead now last night
you tweeted out congratulations to joe
biden and kamala harris um but you also
said
that some of the processors are still
playing
out what did you mean by that
well it's a statement of fact that we
haven't had the state the formal
statement by the
um uh electoral college and of course
there are the appeals going on and we've
you know i make no apology as foreign
secretary for trading very sensitively
and carefully
uh whilst we waited for the clarity and
the result
we've got that clarity um and we offer
the new administration
president-elect uh biden vice
president-elect uh harris our full
support
and look forward to working with them in
the future but i think it's right that
we're careful to respect the
sensitivities
and indeed the integrity of the us
process that's incumbent on me as
foreign secretary
you say you have to be careful and
respect the sensitivities
but some would argue that's exactly what
the tweet doesn't do because you know
we've all heard donald trump allege that
fraud
has taken place that the election has
been stolen from him without evidence
do you not accept that some might see
that tweet as playing into those
conspiracists
no i think that's a very partisan skew
on it the reality is
uh we want to respect the integrity and
the processes in place
um it's not for us to start adjudicating
on the
appeals the legal claims and the counter
claims but what we have said the result
is now very clear uh i think it's beyond
a reasonable doubt
uh in my view and we welcome the the new
administration we congratulate
uh president-elect biden vice
president-elect harris
um and frankly there are those that want
to criticize the uk at this point in
time
come what may and whatever we say
whatever this government says
i'm going to focus on the substance but
i do think people complain
about interference in our politics here
i think it's right to trade carefully
and sensitively
in relation to particularly after what
was clearly a very close election far
closer than the
media or the pundit under it's expected
and has been contentious in all sorts of
ways
so we'll we'll you know we proceeded um
sensitively and carefully we wanted to
respect the process
but we look forward to working with the
new administration
do you think that all votes should be
counted in a democratic collection
look uh i'm not going to get drawn into
pining on what is a different system in
the u.s
well i can say am i sit from the outset
on sorry sorry
the question is do you think all votes
should be counted in a democratic
election i find it astonishing
there's not an answer to that well
because what you're going to
if i say yes and there's an appeal that
goes one way i mean we know for example
there's going to be recounts okay
we know that in relation to some of the
state seats we know in relation to some
of the senate seats
but we we can also say that the result
is clear now and i don't think that's
preempting those other processes which
is exactly why
i said we should tread sensitively to
respect the
integrity of the process and we've
always said and i've been very clear all
week
we're very confident the checks and
balances in the u.s system that will
produce a definitive result
and and i think we've got one now but
i'm not asking about appeals i'm not
asking about checks and balances
i'm literally just saying should all
votes be counted in a democratic
election
okay in principles yes of course and
well i'm not going to get drawn so why
didn't you just say that then
because because what you're really
trying to do sophie is drag me in
to the legal claims about whether or not
all the votes
have probably been counted when you look
at the mail votes
uh the votes in person and the claims
that have been made for example about
the posted military ballots so i just
don't want to get sucked into that we've
got it clear appearance
just i'm not i'm not trying to suck you
into anything with respect mr rabb
i'm just trying to ask i'm the reason
i'm asking the question is because
the uh prime minister spokesperson
wouldn't say that all votes should be
counted in a democratic election early
this week which
frankly i find quite astonishing and i
was just wondering if you would say the
same thing
it's obviously you're reluctant to as
well no your your next question will be
well if all votes should be counted we
haven't had all votes counted
why are you welcoming the new
administration and the reality is the
result now is clear
none of the other processes which i've
uh
referred to which are ongoing will
affect i think the outcome
of this race and i think that's the
approach that people have taken in the
united states and that's the
approach the uk has taken along with
other international leaders
generally that wasn't going to be my
next question i was assuming that you
would say
yes to that question well
look then someone else will say well
why aren't we waiting for all the votes
um to be counted in
including all the reruns uh and the
recounts
before we step in and say we welcome the
result uh i think what we do is wait
until the result is clear beyond doubt
it is now
we welcome uh president-elect uh biden
and vice president-elect harris we're
looking forward to working with them we
really don't want to so if you get drawn
into the cut and thrust
of the controversies the claims and
counterfeits either in the election or
in the immediate aftermath
and that's because we respect americans
right to choose themselves and we
respect
the checks and balances in the american
system which will produce as they have
a clear result okay now i'm keen of
course to talk as well about the
copy 19 lockdown uh that we're having in
england now um now when the prime
minister announced it last weekend he
said
in this country the virus is spreading
even faster than the reasonable
worst case scenario of our scientific
advisors
what was that worst case scenario
what we've been concerned about all
along is that
even as we make progress in some areas
and there have been illustrations of
that that the uh
exponential rise the and the combination
with the r8 moving well beyond one
but also prevalence increasing in
certain areas
means that the nhs leading into
christmas will be overwhelmed that we'd
be hit with
a higher fatality rate and if you look
at the two weeks data
leading up to the saturday that you
refer to when the prime minister made
his decision
we saw a nine uh a a uh
90 increase in hospital emissions a 65
increase in ventilator bed usage and
that is often the precursor to more
fatalities so
i think we did see a very rapid and
fluid uh change in the behavior of the
virus and upper ticking it
and we wanted to crack down on that and
come down as swiftly
and decisively as we could now we were
shown a series of slides last saturday
to justify
the lockdown and we were told that daily
deaths would reach 1500 with one
scenario saying it could be as high as 4
000.
now those figures have since been
revised down
is the government just showing us the
scariest data on this
no look we show models which show what
could happen if certain
uh scenarios play out we've corrected
the slide you referred to
um and it was the the wealth of
scientific information that comes
forward we're trying to be as
transparent
as possible of course it's constantly
initiative process and if
mistakes are made or um facts have to be
changed then that's the point of
transparency
but i think the case for the measures
we've taken is very clear
we want to get through uh to the second
december at that point we will
transition
to uh back to a localized approach it's
always been our preference
but we need to get the uh our rate and
the prevalence of the
of the virus down and use the next few
weeks
to do that of course no one is trying to
underplay
the seriousness of the situation and in
no way am i trying to say that the
decision to look down
was right or wrong there are others far
more qualified than me
to make those calls but you know the
policy was justified by some
scary data that's now been revised down
as you say uh theresa may said this week
that for many people
it looks as if the figures are chosen to
support the policy
rather than the policy being based on
the figures does the public deserve some
more transparency here
well we the transparency is we're
putting a lot of data out there and when
there's a mistake with it we change it
and so we respond
to this very scrutiny that transparency
brings i think that's the right thing we
we're trying to be as transparent as
possible i think the scientists
particularly uh chris whittie and
patrick vance have done a sterling job
it's very difficult uh the the science
is never
entirely clear it's constantly contested
and with a new pandemic and a
virus that behaves in unprecedented ways
that we we're learning about every day
um it's right that the science is
constantly evolving in terms of what we
know
but as i said the the two weeks leading
up to the saturday which the pm
announced the latest set of national
restrictions
has shown very clearly a big rise in
hospital admissions and a big rise
in ventilator bed usage and that's the
point at which we know not only is there
a clear threat
um to people's health and particularly
we worry about people losing their lives
but also the threats of the nhs becoming
overwhelmed and i think that case was
very clear
but of course we put the data out there
if it's incorrect then
the very point of the transparency is to
allow it to be challenged and we make
the best judgments that we can
made on the basis of the best data and
science that's made available to us
okay now you ban travel from denmark
to the united kingdom without exemptions
because of the coronavirus mutation
there that's been linked to mink
and there is a suggestion that this new
mutation may prove
more resistant to a vaccine how worried
should we be
about this well look we've taken a
precautionary measure i spoke to my
danish opposite number
on friday we need to look very carefully
at the science i think the danish
government are being very
uh forward-leaning and transparent and
cooperative about this but what the
concern is
that uh will you see a mutated version
of coronavirus
and that if it if it spread
it would undermine our ability to make
an effective vaccine in the future
because it would
allow the virus to root round so
although it's a precautionary step
i think it is the right step whilst we
engage with all of the health experts
around the world with the danish
authorities and be clear about
what's happened in denmark in particular
in relation to
uh the mints thank you uh very much
for being on the program donald trump i
know you're isolating at the minute as
well so i hope you're feeling well
i don't have grown advice but um i was
in contact with someone who has tested
positive and
you know it's frustrating it's
inconvenient but we've all got to follow
the rules that's the way we get through
this
um absolutely um thank you very much for
being on dominic rob then my pleasure